hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
insights to heart development and
disease using
single cell analysis and in vitro
modeling of
potent stem cells i'm susie valdez of
labrutz and i will be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by
lab roots and brought to you by sony
biotechnology
to learn more visit them at
sonybiotechnology.com
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting as many questions as
you have during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
i'd now like to welcome our speaker dr
peter anderson
an assistant professor as a group leader
and group leader at
johns hopkins university school of
medicine and co-founder of vita
therapeutics for a full biography of our
speaker
please click on the biography tab at the
top
right of your screen peter welcome you
may now
begin your presentation sir
all right thanks for that introduction
my name is
peter anderson and i'm an assistant
professor at the division of cardiology
at johns hopkins school of medicine i'm
also a founder of
vita therapeutics which is a biotech
company that focuses
on developing ips-based therapies
today i'm going to talk a little bit
about how we use
prolonged stem cells as a model system
to study some of the
fundamental aspects of cardiovascular
development
and disease my research
is largely focused on early heart
development
and congenital heart defects with a
particular focus
on general biology
my lab we combine genomic approaches
with
high content androgen imaging and flow
based technologies such as prototyping
and facts to study these multicellular
events
in complex tissue down to a single cell
so for this webinar today i'm going to
briefly go over the
current approaches to differentiate
proponents themselves
with an emphasis on the cardiac lineage
and
cardiac differentiation and then i'm
going to go over some of the approaches
to use
purported stem cells to study early
heart development and demonstrate how we
are able to recapitulate and model
events associated with
chamber specific abnormalities in this
system
and finally i'm going to go over and
visually
in a viewer-based approach where we
developed a maturation system to mature
embryonic cardiomyocytes
and which allow us to study age-related
cardiomyopathies that manifest during uh
adult sense and not outside
so um many of you here are probably very
familiar with programs themselves so
i'll just briefly go over this slide
when we talk about program stem cells we
generally refer to
embryonic stem cells and induced
proportion stem cells
embryonic stem cells are typically
derived from the
inner cell mass of the blastocyst
which makes them ethically challenging
to to work with
whereas induced peripotent stem cells
are generated from
somatic cells that are reprogrammed back
to approved from the state by
introducing
the so-called yemen factors
now ips cells i mean they offer
great computer potential because they're
derived from the patient's own cells
they're genetically mass to that patient
so they can
eliminate tissue matching and rejection
by the patient's immune system which is
a common problem that
hinders successful transplantation ips
cells
are also a valuable research tool for
understanding how
different issues they develop so
together both uh embryon stem cells and
ipso
they have the capacity to solve renewal
and to develop into the three primary
parameters
exodus endogenous term
and eventually into all the cell types
that we have in our body
these differentiated cells can then be
used for everything from disease
modeling
to validation of drugs in efficacy and
fat toxicity studies
which is now commonly used in the
biomedical industry when evaluating
new compounds in vitro
so since the first human embryonic stem
cell signs were derived from
human blastocyst in 1998 by thompson and
colleagues there's been a tremendous
interest in
using ipscs to study stem cells to
develop
both disease models and as you can
introduce mutation into these cells
as well to potentially regenerate
damaged tissue
the way we started to culture and
differentiate these cells was by
generating cellular aggregates term
that we kind of termed them embryo
bodies that you can see here
these embryo bodies were then
differentiated
using protocols that was based on
spontaneous differentiation and
this spontaneous approach was a very
efficient approach
as typically you're only able to
develop about one to three percent of
the cells that you're interested
in in this system um
however this way of differentiation was
still the gold standard
uh as late as uh in 2000
you know i would say 2010.
so right around that uh
time um there was a switch in
in the field where uh labs started to
use
more um they got rid of the serum based
protocol
and started to use these defined serum
free medias
and doing that and when we also at the
same time followed the principle of
development
we started to generate differentiation
protocols that rely
on stepwise differentiation using either
cytokines
small molecules to activate and block
signaling pathways
to first you know differentiate the cell
into the three germinators that i just
mentioned
and then towards specific means of
interest
again by following the principle of
development hereby dramatically increase
these protocol efficiencies
and now in addition to some of these
protocols on many of these protocols
they're in fact so efficient that
they can robustly yield more than 90 of
the cell type
of interest so because
there was such a big interest in
differentiating only the specific cells
of interest most of these protocols they
were also
non-layer based as you can see here so
that was around that time that
all protocols start to kind of become
modern
monolayer based protocols but then
within the recent couple years there has
been a push
back to the three-dimensional uh
protocols again
where more and more and less i started
to focus
on organic technology
and basically ergonomic technology
they provide more cellular complexity to
the system
which often better reflect a given
organs properties
and and thus making them more useful
and relevant as disease models and as
these models they can be used
in validation studies of drugs
and scientific system studies etc
so when we um talk about cardiac
differentiation
uh many of these protocols they they're
very similar when it comes to different
shade
uh mouth as well as human protons
themselves
the only thing that really differs
between the protocols
between mass and human is actually the
timing
most of the cytokines or the small
molecules we use to differentiate these
cells
they are the same and the most common
method of differentiation
are induction of mesoderm by
temporal activation of the wind
signaling typically through
division of gsk3 beta with a small
molecular compound or by co-treatment
with
the cytokines acting a and bp4
both of these approaches they push
performance themselves towards the
measurement of faith
which can be evaluated by analyzing
expression of some of the genes that i
highlight here
as cells they then start to commit to
the cardiovascular lineage
and they differentiate into progenitors
which is that stepwise process
then at some point if you're interested
in making myocytes
inhibition of wind tightening seemed
pretty crucial
and so so as when you look at both of
these protocols you see that they start
off by
you know an induction of wind and then
later on inhibition of of wind
so when we do this uh innovation wind
we force the cells into the
cardiomyogenic
lineage and as as with the cells we
differentiate from the pure from stem
cells
and and the cardiomyocytes that we
generate
these cardiomyocytes they unfortunately
do still remain
embryonic that means that they resemble
a state that is similar to the state of
cells that we or cardiomyocytes
in during this late gestation in the
developing fetus
at this point we we are now able to
produce
different subtypes of cardiomyocytes
and there's a lot of research going into
this but
some of the interesting research have
shown that
you know if you manipulate uh
retinoid acid pathways by either adding
retinoid acid or blocking
the retinoic acid pathway you can push
the cell towards an atrial versus
ventricular fade
and you can also
make changes to the protocol so you can
potentially also push the cell
into these xenoatrial node cells
all right so for this next part
i want to talk well i want to show you
how
we are using the the ps uh the
peripheral stem cell system
uh and how we have used to develop a
model system
to study hard field specification and
development of
the individual heart fields
so just to give a quick
idea of why we're doing this so so early
heart defects
are a frequent source of mortality
estimated to account for
as many as 30 percent of embryos that
are lost before birth
and almost one percent of newborn babies
are born with
a form of congenital heart defect which
actually
makes congenital heart disease the most
frequent type of
birth defects in humans the pathogenesis
of
congenital heart abnormalities
is largely unexplored and one of the
reasons for that is
due to the embryonic origin and the
inability to obtain tissue from from
patients which
kind of makes sense um so
in mammals the heart develops from two
sets
of molecular and phenotypic distant
progenitors referred to the first and
second heart field
as you can see here this drawing the
first heart field
is is visualized in red whereas the
second heart tool is visualized in blue
and as you can also see here the first
heart field gives rise to
uh certain parts of the heart whereas
the second high field gives rise to
other parts of the heart so
the first heart fuel gives rise to the
left ventricle and
and part of the atria whereas the second
heart field
uh exclusively gives rise to the outflow
tract
and the right ventricle and and
it makes sense that that abnormal
general development
is closely associated with the theology
of congenital heart defects so one of
the questions we asked ourselves was
whether it was possible to develop
a pluripotent stem cell based model
system to study heart fuel specification
and potentially allows to model
congenital development and chamber
specific events that are associated with
congenital heart disease
so as i just showed here in my previous
slide
about the first and second conf field
you know the heart
is comprised of these two heart fields
uh
so so so what we did for the study we
started off by
visualizing and monitor heart field
specification in vivo
and to do that we analyze the expression
domains of several
known genes uh that have been associated
uh with the first heart field in the
second heart field and we use the mouse
to do that
and i'm not going to show you all that
for the sake of time of this
presentation
i just want to show that we did identify
two genes that that literally
marks the first and second heart field
as we've seen these developing mice
so we here here we have uh developing
mouse embryos at
eight days post fertilization and nine
nine days post fertilization
and all we can see here is the first
hospital
is marked by gfp which is driven by the
gene
htm4 so fgm issue iv was a gene that is
solely expressed in the first heart
field whereas tbx1
exclusively expressed in the second hot
fuel and it's driving expression of rfp
so what you can see here on these
pictures to the left
is that these two hard fields can be
identified in this mouse model
and it's in a non-overlapping manner so
it's a really nice tool
to to to basically follow these for
generals
throughout their development and in
building the
the heart in these mice so
for us to develop a study in vitro or in
the peripheral potential system
we then next re-derived embryonic stem
cells from these
mouse crossings with the correct
hemotype and and thereby you know
providing us with the capability to
potentially monitor first and second
heart field
development in vitro by literally
evaluating gfp and rfp expression
so the first thing we did was we devised
a
differentiating protocol based on on the
embryo body technology
meaning basically cellular aggregation
to generate a 3d environment to resemble
the individual environment as as much as
possible
and as you can see here you know once we
form these
uh infrared bodies or spherical uh
clusters
we then uh subject them into a
differentiating protocol
as i was explaining earlier you know
where we are
inducing the the music induction
in this case by uh treating the the
embryonic bodies with acid and bt and
then
at a later stage uh the question was are
we going to see hospitals participating
in these and
we actually were hypothesis that we're
going to see
gfp and rfp as a way to identify the
first and the second heart field and
this is exactly what we did so when we
look at the picture here at the bottom
we see that uh after we've we've
driven this induction by acting on bmp
see over time
we start seeing information of these
separate domains
that are either rfp and dsp positive and
they're adjacent to one another
very much uh similar to to the enviro
scenario where we see the two heart
fields developing
adjacent to one another
um so the next thing we did uh was to
first identify which of these
concentrations uh
um which of these methods uh
gave us the best induction of
cardiogenesis
so as you can see here this is where we
test out
uh an increasing dose of bmp
as you can see in the top and then also
we have an increasing dose of accident a
as you can see out to the right and then
we're doing uh
a scatter plot here of all the of
current profile and t here so we picked
out the the treatment of well
the condition that gave us the most
amount of
cardiotropin t positive cells here so
cardiac from t uh marks cardiomyocyte
and as you can see
the the condition highlighted in red
is the one that gives us 36 percent this
is just
an immediate time here that we pick that
condition
and then at the same time
we evaluated the expression of g of p
and r of p
so when we look at this condition here
we can we can
see here that uh that g
of p is at the y axis
and rfp is at the x axis and we can see
that we get a nice formation of gfp
plastic cells
as well if we get an isolation of our
feedback itself
so that kind of indicates that we are
actually forming
first and the second heart field for
generals in this system
but to make sure that these also what's
validated that these cells are actually
also
cryogenic we then cultivate these cells
a little longer
and then we analyze
the expression of cartilage quantity
again as you can see out to the right
we isolate the gfp particle cells
and we could see that 89 of them were
actually uh
expressing uh cardiac current t as a
sign of being
myocytes and whereas about fifty percent
of the cells um expressed are uh
sperm t in the rfp population from the
second heart field
and this goes very well with the
literature because
in the literature um we already know
that the first heart field
is primarily a unipotent
cardiomyogenic heart field
meaning this heart field doesn't only
give rise to
cardiomyocyte whereas the second
hospital is
is a multi-potent heart field that can
give rise to
different types of tissue or different
type of cell sites in the heart
so it makes sense that 50 of them on my
side
we actually have more data showing that
it also gave rise to the
vascular immune system smooth muscle
cells as well
i'm not going to show that here for the
second time
so the next question we had was how
similar are these cells generating
vitro to their individual counterparts
so to answer this question we performed
rna sequencing on gfp and rp parts of
cells
in vivo as well as vitro this rna
sequencing analysis
revealed a high correlation between vivo
and
vitro cardiogenesis literally telling us
that
it's a very similar gene expression
profile between the two states
and both in vitro's early and vivo and
giving us confidence that the system
actually works and we are generating uh
first heartfelt degenerative technology
um so in in that process we identified
approximately 1500 genes that was
differentially regulated between
gfp and rp process cell
and of these about 75 percent of the
cells were enriched in both
gfp and oxycodone cells suggesting that
our spheroid system
really recapitulate early heart fuel
development and specification
so we next asked whether we could use
this system to identify pathways
that are involved in the specification
and development of the individual heart
fields
to do this we did an engineering
pathway analysis also called an ipa
analysis
of these enriched genes and we
identified relatively few pathways that
were differentially regulated
so as you can see here the green bars
they represent
first hot field cells or gfp plastic
cells
whereas the red bars they represent
second hot fuel cells
are peacocks themselves so the higher
activity
of actin cytoskeleton and taxing
paxillin signaling likely reflects the
presence of the structural genes being
transcribed in the first heart field
so so what we focused on was the actual
pathways of bmp and wing state line
because as you can see there bmb
pathways
was highly overestimated in the first
high fuel versus
the second hot field whereas the wind
signaling pathways were
highly up regulated in the second hot
field versus
the um the first hot tube
so this tells us that uh somehow these
two different
pathways they play a specific role
within the individual heart field so
in order to test that we um
we tested where the pmp and wind system
they actually regularly specifications
of the first and second half fuel in our
problem stencil system
so first we uh we analyzed the effect of
bp signaling and as you can see here we
find that bmp
induced specification of
gfp-positive progenitors in a
dose-dependent manner
and then when we when we did the same
study we
tested out the canonical wind
molecule with 3a we could see that
increasing dose of 0.3a actually
resulted in
a dose-dependent manner of
the second hot fuel cell but didn't
affect uh
formation of the first hot field and
what was
really interesting was that uh when we
treat these cells with bmp alone
we see that we see formation of first
hot fuel cell
and uh second hot fuel cell indicated by
the the green and red bar uh out to
the barcraft to the far right and then
when we add in wind to that system we
see that
we're actually not affecting the first
house field
we're increasing the formation of the
second high field and at the same time
when we block wind secretion this can be
done
by uh adding the protocol inhibitor
iwp2 we actually see that we're still
seeing information of the first hospital
in presence
of the mp4 but the
induction of the second high field is
dramatically diminished so
literally uh that kind of takes us to
the current working model that we had is
that
we we worked out in this paper that
um bmp signaling uh dry formation of
the first heart field uh but at the same
time
first heart fuel secrete uh wins
that uh dry formation of the second
heart field
and that's actually what we're working
from from
now and i'm just gonna
move over and explain a little bit more
about how we use the system
to identify a service marker
to also uh identify these
itself so when we looked again into our
data or our rnc data
we were we wanted to see if we could
identify
these progenitors by the expression of
service receptors
so one of the service receptors we found
that was highly upregulated
in the second hot fuel progenitors was a
gene
called a certain expression called cxcl4
dpf4 is a well-known receptor that's
involved in
migration of certain progenitors
and and and we found it interesting that
was highly up right
up regulated in the second heart field
pretenders but not in the first half of
the universe
so we turned back into our system and
this time
we we used another uh pluripotent
stencil line
this time being driven by the cardiac
potential margaret that drive rfp
so we can take these cells and we
analyze them for cfto4 expression and
what we actually find here is that
within that population of regenerators
we can we can identify an explanation
that expresses cpl4
and one that is not expensive therefore
when we take these two populations and
we actually test them in cloning assays
uh from uh
by qpcr we can see again that
the the population that is not expressed
in cfco4
is largely cardiomyogenic
as we would expect from progenitors from
the first heart field
whereas we see at the cell type
that expresses co4 which we believe are
the second heart filter generators
and it's more like a multi-protein cell
type
giving rise to all the areas image
of the heart
so next we also want to show
whether we could actually develop this
system
for human ipfcs
so as you can see here we devise a very
similar
protocol this time it's human
with no transgenic markers at all
but because we have the information of
cpo4 we believe
that we could use up4 to potentially
identify
first and second heart field so in the
human system when we're taking human
nuclear cells
we're forming forming these anchor gauge
and we're differentiating them very
similar to the muscles that
i just mentioned and at the right given
stage
which is about five five and a half days
after
we start the protocol we um
we try to see uh whether we can see a
difference in terms of
ccf4 expression and as you can see here
down in the scatter plot
in the lower left see that there
actually is
a population that expresses cf4
and the population that doesn't express
coco4 so when we sort these
two populations up you can see that both
of them
are very cardiogenic which is
expected as it is a cardiogenic protocol
in both cases where about more than 70
of the cells are expressing either with
the transcriptional marker of cardiac
units
but when we then um analyze these cells
for
for the gene expression we see that the
cfto4 negative cell
seems to have a high enrichment of
genes that are associated with the first
heart field 184 tbx5 and geno4
whereas uh the ckc of a positive cell
opposite they do not express these
markers but they have expressed
the markers that are associated with the
second heart field so exactly what we
were expecting
and as you can see out to the to the
right we see that
again the population um
that is 64 negative is is largely
cardiomyogenic
whereas the population that refers we
believe
refers to the second heart field is a
little less cardiogenic
so it makes sense and show that
our system can be used to also isolate
the first and second half
in human ips cultures
so so next
i wanted to talk a little bit about how
we also are able to use this system to
to model change specific uh disorders
using
full consensus um so
you can see here on my next slide
uh one of the things uh one of the first
uh genes we want to uh
events that we want to look at was um
the
hog arm syndrome which is caused by
a mutation in the gene called tbx5
so in the animal model or in the mouse
what happens when we lose expression of
tbx5
we end up with a very underdeveloped
left
ventricle and this makes sense because
tbx5 is very important for
development of the first heart field so
this is where our system potentially
could
could show us where we if if we're able
to
to use this to specifically
pinpoint whether there's a mutation
where the genes are affecting either the
first or the second heart field
and as you can see here in this as it is
a pretty simple assay
where we are differentiating our
spheroids
and we then knock down tbx5
and as we can see here is that knockdown
tb5
dramatically reduces the formation of
carbon monoxide
in the first hot field but it doesn't
affect the second heartburn
so literally showing that we can
actually use this system to study
these uh chamber specific events
and that's another example here
we have the gene tbx1 which is actually
one of the genes that we use to identify
the uh
the hospital um but a deficiency of tbx1
is actually linked to a condition called
uh george syndrome and which is
associated with
abnormalities of the alpha tract so in
this case
here uh deletion of tbx1 we would expect
that it would only affect the second
heart field
because the off-road track is derived
from the second hard field
this is exactly what we see you see here
that
when we delete uh tbx1 in the first high
field of the dfp parts itself
we don't see any statistical difference
between
uh knocked down and not whereas um
when we knocked down gtx1 and the
arthropods itself we see a dramatic
reduction in proliferation of these
cells
so this again confirms that the system
can be used
to model these chamber specific events
and just lastly i want to go another
study which
is actually done with a collaborator in
copenhagen
um where they had a project where they
were evaluating
uh mice that was sufficient for a
and what they had seen in this in their
minds was that it seemed that they had
an
abnormal outflow track development so
again
here we tested our system
and and deleted uh smurf1 in
in in our system and the ex we would
expect only to see
um an effect on the second hard field
and this is exactly what we see here we
see that
when we lead smurf one in this system
see that it only affects the
cardiomyogenesis
in the second half field but not the
first half field
so again this kind of validate
this whole system and and and really
excited us because it gave us it has
given us tools
studying these chambers specific events
um in a plural stem cell system
all right so before we move to the next
part of my talk
uh where i demonstrated how we
are going to use how we use the protocol
essential system to identify a role
of wind signaling information of uh
second heart fuel progenitors
i want to use these few slides to show
how we use the mouse model
to validate our findings from the
pluripotent central system
and how we use the chromium platform
from 10x genomics
to investigate the impact of wind
signaling during hospital specification
and formation of the embryonic heart
as you can see here we have here mice
and basically it's 18 4g p so
identifying the first hot fuel so you
can see here that
the um the lift ventricle is
expressing gfp because that's derived
from the first hot field
but in this case here what we did we
deleted a gene called windlass
and windlass is responsible for
cell to secrete with so when we delete
windlass that means that cells can no
longer secrete
with and what we see here is
that in our control mice we get a normal
heart where we see the outflow trap
and the right ventricle they're not gfp
positive because they're derived from
the second heart field
and out to the left you can even see
that uh you have the rb
and it's not expressing the the first
hospital now the tbx5
but when we then look at the windlass
mutant embryos we now see that we don't
see
a formation of right
ventricle and furthermore
we can see that basically we only get
one ventricle
and the entire ventricle is tbx5 so
literally
showing that we are not able to form the
second heart field in these mice
so that kind of ties back to what we
found in the system was that
that specification of the second hot
seal
relies on formation of the first hard
field to secrete winds
so when we don't have the first high
field being able to
secrete winds we are not able to induce
the second heart field
so we next here employed a
multi-secreting approach where we used
um
sp1 to to drive expression of
tea tomato to identify
the mesoderm derivatives in these mice
and we then had windlass
deleted as you can see up to
the left corner
so the stages that we analyzed was e 8.0
e 8.5 and e 9.5
and we then after that we barcoded the
cells
um using the genex chromium platform
and then solve the cell so we can
isolate
the cells that derive from riester as
only those cells are rp positive
when we take these cells we create these
umap plots
we can identify all the structures
within the mesterman
lineage here now
one thing that we're very interested was
obviously to
look into the low end pathways so
as you can see here the what we what we
identified here was
actually only a subset of wind that was
actually expressed
uh within the measly important
proportion here
and what's kind of striking me is that
the first heart field
they express high levels of win2 which
actually called
our previous finding while the posterior
second heart field expressed only low to
detectable levels of winds
now the outflow track uh cali my size
they highly
expressed wind 5a and wind 11 which are
actually both
known for their roles in afro-chat
development but they're also
both members of the non-canonical uh
wind family so this this data actually
further supports our hypothesis that
the first heart field may be the source
of the instruction
and structure to win and i'm specifying
the second half field
so so we then uh here performed
a trajectory reconstruction of
controlled
knockout cells in the second half field
using a monocle
so by using molecule we reconstruct
a branch trajectory in which controls
and knockout cells are largely
in distinguishable here at
8.0 um before we can see that they
actually reach these separate states
at later time points so
we subsequently use this trade sheet
to identify genes that are
differentially expressed across
the control and knockout path at a
branch point
focusing on genes with different chances
of expression at the
end stage so here we identified around
uh
i think it was 750 genes which we
classified into four crosses based on
the gene expression domain dynamics
so in general go chairs relevant to
heart development were enriched in
operating
pain classes shown out here to the right
and
while go turns related to cell cycle and
for enriched and down regulated clusters
and just to further show that we
look at some of the individual genes and
what we generally see
is that genes as i just mentioned that
are associated with the cell cycle
are kind of down regulated
um here whereas we see that
uh genes that are associated with
chiromyogenesis are tend to be
upregulated
in the control cell uh
i'm sorry in the in the given knock
ourselves and what we can further see
out here
uh in the embryos that have been uh
treated with edu uh we can see that
there's
uh drop and proliferation in within the
the second furniture arch uh just
demonstrating
that the progenitors when the second
pretty large
have lost their proliferation
potential and what we were able to
conclude from this study was that
premature differentiation of secondary
second heart failure
generators and increasing proliferation
as a key mechanism to
for this knockout hot feel type
so literally all in all that kind of
shows us what
we were able to do we were able to uh
identify
a role for wind signaling in in the
purple and stem cell system
in this new model that we've created and
we actually end up validating in the
mouse system
to actually show that we're able to
answer some specific questions in terms
of wind signaling and
their effect on on early high
information
so just to finalize this for today
i'm just going to spend a few more
slides
on talking a little bit about maturation
and how we develop a a system to study
in maturation in human myocytes
to study these adult concert diseases
phenotype that we see
so as i mentioned on my one of my
earlier slides the
cardiomyocytes that we generate from
either induced proportions themselves or
ever have sensors
they retain these immature
characteristics
uh they're i would say they're fetal
like
and they kind of stuck in that state
there is a lot of push to
to get these cells to mature but i don't
think anyone has really
identified some some
factors that can get them into the final
mature state
or at all state as a myosite and as we
when we look here the
the image here we can see that you know
um
typical myocytes that from
the stem is a small round cell it's very
disorganized in terms of the sarcomeres
whereas when you look at the picture in
the
far right corner we see that
a true envelope myself is an
elongated cell rectangular shape
with a very nice organized structure
so what we did for this uh study we were
asking like
so what is it that makes the cells uh
suck
um the maturation uh so basically
they seem to be stuck in a in a state
and what we have already seen from other
studies and we've also done some of
these studies ourselves
when we took these embryonic
cardiomyocytes and injected them into
infected models or adult hearts
we saw that they couldn't grasp not very
efficient but the embryonics then uh
cardiomyocyte they didn't grab but they
remained and retained their immature
characteristics they remained this
inorganized structure they didn't have
a proper sarcomere alignment
so we then asked ourselves so
what is that make the difference and we
started to think like
well what if we potentially inject cells
at an earlier stage
because we know that cells from
from from birth are maturing throughout
the adulthood so we tested this
hypothesis of injecting embryonic
cardiomyocyte into newborn newborn rats
and
basically here's the scheme for this
project you know we we differentiate
uh embryonic stem cells uh or ips cells
in uh using the protocols that i
explained earlier
and then we take these cells and inject
them into the heart of newborn rats and
we wait
four to eight weeks until the the rat
actually reached adolescence or even the
become an adult and the heart has
probably matured
so surprisingly what we see here and
what we found was
that when we did this and this didn't
matter whether we
injected a rat esl or whether we
injected mouse and burning stem cells we
saw that these injected
embryonic cardiomyocytes they were able
to
undergo full maturation within
the host within the actual
part so what we can see here is that
the cells that we were able to attract
and extract from these uh
animals uh when they were at an anal
state
were highly organized and resembled all
the characteristics of an
adult and myocyte and when we quantify
their you know maturation statement in
terms of
nucleation stages it's well known that
cardiomyocyte when they mature
they undergo a process called
bionucleation
we see that these amounts in brown
extensors
or embryonic cardiomyocytes will be
injected
undergo binding creation very similar to
the rats
host thymyocytes indicating that these
cells are actually undergoing uh
full maturation we then performed
a numbers of different assays to these
single cell-based assays to show that
these cells they actually
have all the functional probability
probabilities of
an carbon monoxide and to a lot of
extent we see
that they resemble or more like
intermost
so we even tested that with
human ips derived cardiomyocyte and we
see the same thing where we see
a complete
state of a human cardiomyocyte here
so when we again did some single fill
based on ac and here we show that the
pca plot we can see that the cells
that we have matured or
in in vitro meaning that they're not
undergoing proper maturation
they separate out from the cells
from the adult cells or the anal
cardiomyocyte as well as the
chi myositis that we have matured in
vivo you can see that crosstalk together
here
nicely highlighted in
s blue and green dots
so what we were really interested in
here was that
now it seems that we could mature these
cells
into an adult-like stage so
the question was whether we could also
then use the system
to study these adult onset diseases
and in this case here we were very
interested in
[Music]
arrhythmia genic right ventricular
cardiomyopathy
which is an inherited form of
cardiomyopathy that manifests
only in adolescence or adulthood of
humans
and it's slightly characterized by a
fibro fatty
apoptosis and intercalated disc
abnormalities so what we see here is
when we take the cells and we kind of
mature them in vitro
you see that the cells they retain their
immature uh characteristics
and they don't express any markers that
are associated with
with with disease and and that can see
up here in the
in the far left corner the marker that
i'm referring to here is prolitin
we see no expression of parallelism but
once we take the cell
into our indivo maturation system and we
let them mature
here we can see when we do this with
wild type or
healthy ips cell we don't see expression
of parallelism which
is what we expect because these cells
are from a healthy individual
but when we take um
cardiomyocytes from an amd patient or ip
ips c derived uh myocytes
um we see that they could correlate with
parallel expressions something that
we've never seen in vitro
so just suggesting or demonstrating that
that
the cells are actually undergoing
maturation as we would expect
and when we look at some of the other
parameters we see that there's
a higher percentage of these cells they
tunnel positive as a sign that they are
undergoing apoptosis
and finally we also looked at the
insulate
interpolating disk and we can see here
when we look at the
normal human control we see like this
nice
thin uh inflated disc which is a normal
condition
but when we look at the amd cell
that we have matured in our system
we see that there's a very big
discrepancy
these cells they um they look
kind of off when you look at these discs
so just to summarize that up the last uh
bit that i was talking about here was
our indivo
based maturation system of armstrong
brand stem cells or
human ips cells where we can develop the
cells
you can ingest them into newborn props
and
in a matter of like a month
or so you can have these um fully mature
and adult
uh cells
so with that i'm just gonna stop right
here
question questions
thank you dr anderson for that
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have any questions
you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
so let's take a look we already have
some incoming questions
our first question what are some of the
challenges
associated with working with the
embryonic
spheroid system in general and
specifically when sorting them
for single cell transgress comics
yeah uh no thanks for that question
that's a great question um
so i think you know first of all uh for
working with this protocol and with pro
reports in general
um it's all about re reproducibility
so there's a lot of variability in this
system uh so you want to make sure you
have
some some standardized and reliable
differentiation protocols and that also
goes for this system
that goes down to you know make sure you
you played the exact
correct number of cells etc etc
um so that's for that part and then
um for the actual uh single cell
transcription links um
so so as i showed here uh we used for
some of it we use the 10x
uh platform and and it's it's generally
all about timing
so you want to minimize time
so for the 10x protocol that that
entitles that you have to
be effective effectively barcoding the
cells
before you potentially sort them and
and then uh for the other types of
single cell transcriptomics approaches
i mean we typically use uh a 384 well
plate system that we have already
prepared with the license buffer
then upon sorting we will have a
container next to the solder
uh you know filled with dry eyes so that
we immediately take the place and
plates and flash freeze them right after
sorting
um and then um so typically from
from dissociation of the cells to the
cells have been
sorted and in life it shouldn't take
more than 30 minutes
thank you so much and did you use any
specific approaches for sorting
cardiomyocytes with high variability
viability um
yeah that's that's also a great question
um so
so one of the most um
you know uh important um
steps here is to have a good and robust
uh dissociation protocol
um so so typically a lot of cells they
they tend to die during this state when
you actually dissociate them
um so so make sure you have a good
reliable uh dissociation protocol
then after that i mean we we use
pbs supple that we supplement with with
heaps
typically uh around 10 millimolar
um there's also other uh options out
there for
you know commercially available sorting
solutions uh
that you know somewhat increases the
viability of cells
but but to make sure you know you have a
good
um sorting buffer uh and and
it and as i said it can be as simple as
we do uh pbs without calcium magnesium
that is supplemented with the heaps that
that
works for us and then uh
one important feature i'd say is that to
make sure that the cells are cold
at all time so that you know when we use
our sorting buffer
we pre-cool it we make sure that
everything is
it's cool and then you know if you have
a sorter that is equipped with with
temperature control
that will increase uh viability uh a lot
i mean
for example we use the sony solder
the s800 which has this feature so so i
highly recommend you
you enable the feature if you have it on
your solder
um that will significantly increase
viability
and and then then finally i would say
you know if
if you have different options for for
nozzle sizes
uh you know increasing the nozzle size
will
also increase variability because you
lower the pressure on the
the system and on the cells
thank you so much our next question what
is the expected time
in order for this technique to be used
and the general practices
and what are the expected benefits
um so in terms of time so i think you
know
uh if we probably referring to
to uh the single cell sorting and the
the single
uh omics that i just referred to and and
again i would say you know
you gotta work efficient uh you make
sure you know
uh after you've dissociated cells um
it should take no more than 30 minutes
or so
until you actually have yourself um
ready or lies for for the next steps
thank you so much and peter we have one
more question coming in
this person says my question is about
how to maintain
homogeneity of the generated cms
oh yeah i know that's a that's a good
question and
and and um if you saw my my
you know my earlier slide you know we
can generate
different subtypes of of cardiomyocyte
depending on
on what type of um differentiation
protocol you use right so
so you can you know you can
differentiate them towards the direction
of
atrial myocytes or ventricular myocyte
and and then you know obviously you can
you can you can enrich
these myocytes by by certain sorts and
processes
but in order to maintain
the them in a homogeneous population
and i don't think i have a good answer
to that
uh basically you know
you the the myocytes when they're
differentiated you know they shouldn't
really
um they shouldn't be that heterogeneous
heterogeneous so so so they should be
able to just
keep that you know be locked into that
state
um so i don't i don't really have a good
answer that question
dr anderson i want to thank you for your
time today and for your important
research
and we'd also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor sony biotechnology for
underwriting today's educational webcast
and before we go i also want to thank
our audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed
by our speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's
live event until next time take care
everyone
and bye